compared to gigantic galaxies and star
clusters the solar system is no more
than just a speck of dust
there are thousands of stars within the
radius of a hundred light years from it
with some of them barely distinguishable
against dark abyss of space
others are so bright that they can be
seen even if they're in other galaxies
besides there are a lot of invisible
objects lurking at the depths of space
too
from massive Brown dwarves to Rocky
exoplanets comparable to our Earth and
size
some of them may Harbor life while
Others May pose a threat
however all this diversity is eclipsed
by the scale of our galaxy
there are 200 billion stars and over a
trillion planets at the very least to be
found across its expanses it is quite
impossible to completely explore this
great abundance of unique space objects
today we will talk about some of the
closest ones
by Galactic standards the area of space
on the outer edge of the solar system is
considered to be sparsely populated by
both stars and other space objects
still approximately 50 Stellar systems
are known to be located within the
radius of 15 light years from the Earth
some of them are single Stars While
others contain two components and more
which is why the total number of stars
in this area reaches 65.
many of them have exoplanets and
protoplanetary disks made up of gas and
dust where Celestial body formation
processes are still in progress in order
to analyze this great variety we'll have
to map out the environs
as we slowly recede from our home planet
we will cover dozens of light years of
space and visit quite a few remote
worlds
it is time to set out
to the Stars
having traveled six light years away
from the sun we will reach our first
stop a small red dwarf designation
gj699 also known as Barnard's star
it is remarkable for its incredible
travel speed across the sky and also for
the fact that it's capable of crossing
the lunar disk in the course of 180
years this is due not only to its close
proximity to us but also to its great
proper motion
Barnard's star is moving towards the
solar system at a speed of slightly over
a hundred kilometers per second and is
going to become our closest star in
about 10 000 years
by then the distance between Barnard's
starred our sun will be just 3.8 light
years
but the Red Dwarf is so dim that it will
not be visible even at such a small
distance and it will be possible to
observe it only through optical devices
the star's mass is just 17 percent that
of the Sun and its radius is six times
as smallest out of our star
just like all red dwarves Barnard star
is quite cool with a surface temperature
just
3134 Kelvin or slightly under 2 900
Degrees Celsius
with these characteristics taken into
account it isn't surprising that the
object's Luminosity is 2300 times lower
than that of our parent star in 2018 the
results of a 20-year observation of the
star's proper motion were published
which may provide evidence for the
presence of an exoplanet nearby the
calculations show it to be a code super
Earth with a mass of not less than 3.2
times that of the Earth
the planet named
gj699b is located about 0.4 astronomical
units from the center of the system and
takes 233 days to complete a full orbit
around its parent star unfortunately the
exoplanet follows an orbit that does not
lie between the earth and its parent
star so it's hardly feasible to carry
out spectral analysis of the object
still mathematical modeling may give us
some insights into what it's like
as bonded star is very dim its planetary
companion receives 50 times less energy
than does the Earth from the Sun
that is why the temperature on the
celestial body's surface is extremely
low just 105 Kelvin or 168 degrees
Celsius below zero
however it cannot be ruled out the tidal
disturbances or radioactive decay may
have released enough energy in the
planet's interior to form a warm
subsurface ocean
if that is the case the potential life
in its depths would have had ample time
to gradually develop
for among the known Stars Barnard's star
appears to be one of the oldest
according to estimates its age is over
10 billion years which is only a
fraction of the expected lifespan of a
star
as it is located quite close and is
moving in a favorable Direction
Barnard's star is one of the highest
priority objects for a potential
Interstellar flight time will show if
spacecraft launched from Earth will ever
reach it
meanwhile on the other side of the sun
there lies the almost exact opposite of
the dim red dwarf
of course we're talking about Sirius the
brightest star in the night sky which is
8.6 light years away from our planet
from Earth the star appears to be a
single light source but close inspection
revealed that it is not a single object
but a binary star the two components of
the system are currently at their
maximum distance from each other about
30 astronomical units
the main star also called serious a is a
bright blue and white star with a mass
two times that of the Sun
at the same time it is about 70 percent
larger in diameter and its surface
temperature reaches 10 000 Kelvin
because of this Syria say emits 25 times
more energy than our sun
the second object known as Sirius B is
barely visible against the background of
its bright and massive companion it is a
wide dwarf with a radius of about six
thousand kilometers and a mass very
close to that of the Sun
like all stars of this type its surface
temperature is extremely high reaching
25
000 Kelvin
however due to its small size this white
dwarf is about a thousand times dimmer
than its Stellar companion
after long and persistent research no
signs of planets have been found in the
vicinity of Sirius
the reason for this may lie in the
comparatively young age of the Stellar
system or else the special position of
the ecliptic plane because of this the
hypothetical exoplanets do not pass
between the light source and the Earth
and therefore cannot be detected by the
transit method
another hypothesis claims that serious B
exhausted its Stellar fuel supply
roughly 120 million years ago and
transformed into a red giant
Sun afterwards it shed its outer layers
turning into a compact and very hot
white dwarf
as a result the protoplanetary gas and
dust disk enveloping the young Stellar
system at the time was destroyed by this
explosion its remnants scattered into
space around denying the forming planets
any chance of survival
currently both components of the system
are moving around a common Mass center
in moderately elongated orbits
completing one every 50 years
over the next 60 000 years Sirius will
gradually approach Earth becoming
brighter and more visible in the night
sky
the minimum distance between us will be
about seven and a half light years after
which the system will start to slowly
drift away from us
things will go on like this for about
another 660 million years after which
serious a will meet the same fate as its
companion
for a brief moment a massive flare will
boost its Luminosity by a factor of
thousands
but within a few months the star will
fade completely Vanishing from the sky
forever
leaving the vicinity of Sirius permeated
by lethal ultraviolet radiation and
Stellar Wind we will perform a maneuver
near the solar system to reach a small
star 14 light years from the earth it is
designated differently in different
catalogs and one of its names is Wolf
1061.
the star is a red dwarf with a radius of
about 30 percent that of the Sun
its mass is about four times smaller
than that of our star and its surface
temperature is
3272 Kelvin or about 3000 degrees
Celsius like all objects in its class
wolf 1061 is extremely dim its
Luminosity is only 0.14 percent that of
the Sun so the star is not visible to
the naked eye from Earth
however this red dwarf has one of the
most abundant and diverse planetary
environments of any Stellar system
nearest
as many as three exoplanets have been
discovered in its vicinity all of them
Rocky and similar in composition to
Earth but still conditions on each of
the three celestial bodies differ
considerably
the first are closest exoplanet to the
parent star is called wolf 1061b
it is located
.038 astronomical units from the center
of the system and completes the full
orbit around it roughly every five days
the object has a mass in the range of
one and a half to Two Earths and a
radius twenty percent greater than that
of our planet
it is likely that the celestial body is
steadily locked and faces its star with
one side at all times
for this reason the temperature on the
day side of the planet is extremely high
and the flares and Stellar Winds of the
star so close to it virtually rule out
any chance of there being an atmosphere
all these factors make the exoplanets
completely unsuitable for the Genesis
and support of life
the second object in the system wolf
1061c is located .089 astronomical units
from its star and completes a full orbit
around it roughly every 18 days
thus it is within the habitable zone of
the star and can be considered a
potentially habitable Celestial body
wolf 1061c is about three to four times
more massive than our planet and belongs
to the class of super Earths
observations show that its radius is
about 1.6 times that of Earth while the
gravity on its surface is calculated to
be 60 percent higher than what we're
used to the exoplanet receives
noticeably less energy from its star
than the earth does from the Sun so its
temperature of equilibrium is much lower
it is 223 Kelvin or about 50 degrees
Celsius below zero which is slightly
higher than on Mars nevertheless given
variations in temperature during the day
and from season to season liquid water
May well exist on the surface of the
celestial body with a dense atmosphere
with a pronounced greenhouse effect this
probability is even higher and
conditions on a planet could approach
favorable ones of all the potentially
habitable exoplanets known to date
wolf 1061c is one of the closest
ranking fifth on the list
the third object in the system is called
wolf 1061d
it follows a clearly elongated orbit
with a distance between the parent's
star and the aphelium reaching 0.73
astronomical units
as for the perihelium it lies much
closer to the system's Center just 0.21
astronomical units away
it takes the celestial object about 217
Earth days to complete a full year
rotation
the mass of wolf 1061d is calculated to
be roughly 7.7 times that of our Earth
if this Celestial body turns out to be a
rocky object
its radius is supposed to measure about
1.7 times that of the Earth
if on the other hand this planet falls
in the category of many Neptunes with a
thick multi-layer atmosphere its
diameter is supposed to be not less than
2.2 times out of our planet
in spite of a comparatively High
eccentricity of its orbit wolf 1061d
never enters its star's habitable zone
the celestial body is likely to be
completely unsuitable for supporting
life but may pose a great scientific
interest in terms of planetary Evolution
this system is one of top priority
destinations for future Explorations and
it is highly probable that there are new
discoveries to be soon made in it
in addition to everything else the star
wolf 1061 is also remarkable for its
position
which is virtually at the very edge of
the so-called local Interstellar Cloud
it is an area in space filled with hot
but extremely rarefied hydrogen
its temperature measures about 7000
Kelvin
and on average there is just 0.3 of an
atom to be found in one cubic centimeter
of space here
it is about twice as little as the
average value in the Milky Way the solar
system has been moving through the local
Cloud for the past ten thousand years
its average diameter is about 30 light
years but our system is almost at its
very edge
Alpha Centauri for example is already in
the neighboring so-called g-cloud we on
the other hand will spend about another
2 000 years within our Cloud after which
we will enter an even thinner and hotter
region the local Interstellar Cloud was
formed by the Collision of two giant
bubbles of hot Cosmic gas
it has a momentum of its own which is
perpendicular to the direction of the
Solar System's motion and also has a
magnetic field and radiation
fortunately despite the high energy of
the interstellar gas particles that make
up the cloud there is no threat to
organisms on Earth
the solar wind is a reliable protection
against Cosmic hydrogen and the Earth's
dense atmosphere takes the head of
particles that do break through the
heliosphere
still traces of the isotope ions 60 also
cooled into Stellar iron have been found
in the ice of Antarctica
it is thought to have arrived to Earth
from no other place but the local
Interstellar cloud
as we continue our journey through space
we will soon get to a rather unusual
star called AP colombe located
27.4 light years away from Earth
first and foremost it draws our
attention because it was born just 40
million years ago when the dinosaurs
would have long since died out on our
planet what is even more striking is
that its birth took place in a
completely different region of the
Galaxy
450 light years from the object's
present position
young Stars usually remain close to
their Stellar nursery for quite a long
period of time up to several hundred
million years if you analyze the
movement of AP colombe however you will
find that it probably previously
belonged to the open cluster ic2391
the cluster has about 30 Stars United by
a common origin and direction of
movement but a few million years ago one
of them exploded shattering the delicate
equilibrium of a multitude of cosmic
bodies
this catastrophe gave the youngster an
additional momentum that swiftly
expelled it from his birthplace
a very small red dwarf with a mass just
13 percent that of the sun this time
it's four times more energy than any
other known Celestial body with the same
parameters
in addition its radius is twice as large
as calculated based on the modern
Stellar Structure Theory strangely
enough another unusual feature of the
star has helped to provide answers to
these riddles
according to spectral analysis of its
radiation the Stellar Mata of AP colombe
contains an abnormally large amount of
lithium
normally this element is found in
abundance and protistellar clumps but it
burns out completely after the start of
a thermonuclear reaction
this means that the star is very young
and at the very beginning of its
formation
not even in the main sequence phase yet
as a consequence AP colombe is unstable
and explosive in nature
it is prone to Violent outbursts and
Stellar Mata ejections during which its
Luminosity may increase by up to 10
times for a short while
such events would normally threaten
exoplanets nearby stripping off their
atmosphere and sterilizing their surface
with ultraviolet radiation
as it is observations show that there
are no large space objects within 4.5
astronomical units of this star
in all likelihood it is too young for
the formation of fully fledged planets
nevertheless it is a unique Cosmic body
very important for understanding early
evolutionary stages of stars
as we've seen not every Star has a
planetary system
so our next stop is near the orange
dwarf gleasa 370 37 light years from
Earth
in 2011 a single exoplanet was
discovered near it designated gleasa
370b
the object was discovered with the use
of the radial velocity method and has a
mass of three to four Earths
according to current understanding of
the formation of celestial bodies the
discovered world is most likely a rocky
planet with a radius about 30 percent
larger than the Earth's under such
conditions the gravity on its surface
may be at least 40 percent higher than
what we're used to
Glacier 370b is located at a distance of
0.26 astronomical units from its parent
star and completes an annual rotation in
54.4 Earth days
thus the exoplanet is in a habitable
zone of its star
if the Albedo value of its surface is
close to that of the Earth
then the average temperature of the
celestial body should be about 25
degrees Celsius which is a few degrees
higher than on our Earth
the fact that an exoplanet is located
quite far from its parents star suggests
that it is not tidally locked and has
its own iron or cycle
this contributes to an even a
distribution of heat over the surface of
the celestial body
which is a consequence May create a
milder climate a moderately High Gravity
should smooth out the planet's terrain
which combined with an abundance of
liquid water may cause vast Seas to form
both warm and shallow
such places have traditionally been
considered the most comfortable for the
Genesis and support of life
at the time of its Discovery Glacier
370b was considered one of the most
favorable exoplanets for potential
biological life
however more recent research has
suggested that conditions on its surface
are somewhat less attractive than
previously thought
in particular the atmosphere of the
celestial body may be too dense and have
a pronounced greenhouse effect
still even according to the most
pessimistic predictions the average
temperature on the surface of the object
does not exceed 78 degrees Celsius
which corresponds to a temperature range
of about 30 to 100 degrees Celsius
given that our planet's climate was
about the same During the archaean
period glycer 370b remains a very
promising exoplanet for the search for
extraterrestrial life which means that
its exploration must continue
if we stop and look around for a while
we will find that we have already
traveled more than 50 light years away
from our solar system
there are over a thousand stars within
its radius most of them single Stars
others are binary stars or even groups
of stars the most striking example is
caster a complex and surprising system
of as many as six components
this Stella system is located 50 light
years away from Earth and is visible to
the naked eye as a single source of
light
as the second brightest object in the
constellation Gemini and the 23rd
brightest in the night sky in General
Caster has been known to humans since
ancient times
as the system has as many as six
components it has a rather complex
structure
the two brightest of these cast to A and
B are bluish white serious-like stars
each with a red dwarf companion nearby
the distance between the mass centers of
these binaries is about 110 astronomical
units and it takes them 445 years to
complete a full orbit
about 600 astronomical units from cast
to A and B there is another compact
binary system consisting of a pair of
almost identical red Dwarfs
each has a mass of about 0.6 times that
of the Sun and has a surface temperature
of about
3900 Kelvin
the two stars are so close together that
they take less than 20 hours to complete
a rotation
they move around the system's common
Mass center following a very oblong
elliptical orbit with an orbital period
of about 14 000 years
so far no confirmed exoplanets have been
found in the Caster system
but if they do exist they're most likely
to be located here
the faintest component of the system
in 2018 for example astronomers detected
variations in the orbital period of
Caster sea which implies there may be a
brown dwarf nearby about 49 times more
massive than Jupiter
according to calculations it is located
14 astronomical units from the parent
star and completes the full orbit around
it every 54 years
it is possible that like many red
dwarves cast to see has Rocky exoplanets
close by
in this case the skyline of such a
hypothetical object must present a truly
incredible spectacle on one side a
considerable part of it is occupied by
two Crimson Stars circling the sky
without stopping while on the other side
the Eternal Twilight is diffused by the
light of a pair of stars either of them
hundreds of times brighter than the
Earth's moon
whether this is actually the case can it
yet be verified at this point
although the stars were visited are
great distances apart they're all within
a single structure stretching for the
total of about 300 light years
this is called the local bubble and
contains not only thousands of stars but
also several large structures including
the local Interstellar cloud
the local bubble was formed by
successive explosions of several
supernovae that occurred between 10 and
15 million years ago it has a giant
cloud of interstellar gas heated to 1
million Kelvin because of its high
temperature the gas tends to expand so
its density is about 10 times lower than
the galactic average
in addition the hot ionized hydrogen
constantly emits x-rays fortunately the
magnetic fields of the Sun and the Earth
as well as the atmosphere of the planet
successfully protect us from the harmful
radiation
the local bubble is bordered by other
similar formations
for example slightly away from the
direction of the cellular system's
motion is the so-called bubble one
formed by Supernova explosions in the
vicinity of Antares this giant Cosmic
structure has been actively interacting
with our bubble for a long time which
has caused the formation of tremendous
compactions located at the region at the
edge
the center of the neighboring bubble is
about 500 light years from us and the
solar system will reach its margins in a
few tens of millions of years
clouds of scorching hot gas and open
clusters Giant nebulae and Stellar
streams
all these Majestic Cosmic structures add
up to a single system called galaxies in
turn they combine to form Galactic
filaments giant streams on walls
stretching for billions of light years
this forms the large-scale structure of
the universe
with countless different stars and
worlds lurking in its depths
who knows what we're eventually defined
among them
dear friends this video has taken about
a month of hard and challenging work
it is one of the longest and hopefully
one of the most exciting ones
in the meantime many of you have been
asking about how to support the project
financially so we came up with several
ways of how you can do it if you want to
help our channel in addition to liking
and commenting the sponsorship section
as well as patreon will be available
from now on click join and choose a plan
that suits you best
each sponsor will get a unique audio
greeting personally from me
and will also be invited to a chat where
the latest news about our workflow will
be posted this way you'll get a chance
not only to support our project
but also feel involved in the creation
of new videos
let's keep in touch
thank you